you're teaming up again soon with uh
Robert Eggers for Nosferatu is there
anything you can tell us about
um what you're excited for in that role
or when filming starts um oh I I just
love working with Robert Eggers I I had
a wonderful time I you know I saw the
Witch and I liked it so much I
arranged a meeting with him we liked
each other then I did the lighthouse
which was a fantastic experience and I
think is very good movie then I did a
little part in the Northman which I
really enjoyed and now I get to do this
so I'm just happy to be back with him
it's nosferato his version of Nosferatu
this is why I have this mustache and
that
um because we're shooting now uh I'm I'm
uh I start in just a little bit
um
I'm just excited to be with him again uh
he's a great filmmaker and I enjoy his
company